a civil-rights assistant to the
education secretary is apologizing for
comments she made about campus sexual
assault Candace Jackson told the New
York Times that 90% of campus sexual
assault accusations fall into the
category of we were both drunk in her
apology she called those remarks
flippant education secretary Betsy DeVos
met yesterday with victims of sexual
assault and students who were wrongly
accused the trump's administration may
roll back Obama era guidelines on campus
sexual assault Jan Crawford is at the
Education Department Jam good morning
well good morning so the Obama
administration issued these guidelines
back in 2011 but in the years since
critics say they have swept up innocent
students who are wrongly accused and
yesterday as DeVoss rethinks all of this
she met with people on both sides of
this heated debate this is an issue
we're not getting right in its entirety
Education Secretary Betsy DeVos put it
simply for universities investigating
college sexual assault something has to
change
we need to get this right for students
we need to get this right for families
we need to get this right for
institutions critics say the guidelines
however well-intentioned have gone awry
creating a new class of victims students
who are wrongly accused but I finally
found out that I was being expelled it
was like something hit me in the gut you
know it's not I didn't expect it because
it wasn't the truth former student
Jonathan Andrews says he was falsely
accused of sexual assault in 2015 he met
Thursday with secretary DeVos hoping she
rolls back the Obama era guidelines that
changed how colleges handle sexual
assault cases the pendulum has swung so
far to one side that it's it's guilty
until proven innocent in many cases the
2011 guidelines lowered the standard of
proof for sexual assault an all but
denied cross-examination of witnesses
supporters say the guidelines are
necessary to protect and empower sexual
assault victims my rapist lived in my
door
I had to see him every day ELISA
Peterson is one of those victims
yesterday her organization protested
outside the Department of Education to
persuade DeVos to keep the guidelines in
place it outlines our rights in plain
language to accommodations to counseling
so those have enormous consequences for
survivors but veterans civil liberties
attorneys like nadine strossen the
former head of the ACLU says there's a
better way to protect the victims and
the rights of the accused we have to
avoid miscarriages of justice in either
direction we should get colleges out of
this business
and do it through the criminal justice
system and one other statistic looming
over all of this more than half of these
cases involve alcohol
Jeff Jan Crawford thank you very much